[Música]
eu vim pra dar uma palavrinha com vocês
hoje sobre ontológica o design
ontológico design fala que tudo que a
gente cria cria o mundo de volta tudo
que a sociedade cria molda a sociedade
ao seu redor e isso acontece porque
antes de fazer algo de criar algo a
gente tem que imaginar um comportamento
que se algo vai realizar
então por exemplo a gente imagina que as
pessoas querem se locomover mais
rapidamente
a gente vai lá invento carro as pessoas
começam a se mover mais rapidamente
então aquele comportamento que a gente
imaginou vira realidade
o mundo muda a gente poderia pegar essa
máxima do antológico design e aplicar
porque existe o nosso redor e começar a
tirar algumas conclusões
a gente cria escolas tivessem todos os
alunos e alunas com a mesma roupa faz
com que eles tenham que te responder às
mesmas provas e fazer as coisas nos
mesmos horários a gente está criando
crianças que vão ter aversão a diferença
com 100 integrantes vão ser menos
inventivas menos criativas
a gente cria a necessidade de alimentos
processados que a gente possa comer com
muita paz e da praticidade rápido quanto
microondas está pronto a gente também
cria uma indústria que não vai conseguir
colocar todos os nutrientes necessários
nosso corpo dentro de um alimento
a gente cria relações superficiais
consumo é muito difícil que a gente
pense criticamente ano que está
comprando e consumindo e muito menos a
onde aquilo vai parar depois não foi
mais útil para nós isso a gente cria
relações dentro de prédios e condomínios
são também não são profundas nos
aproxima pessoas
é muito fácil criticar no clichê de
enxergar a pessoa que mora três métodos
nosso apartamento como desconhecido
talvez até um estouro alguém que faz
barulho nos incomoda
eu percebo esses padrões
me incomodo e como um bom ariano para
quem gosta de tecnologia eu decido
incomodar de volta e vejo muito hoje o
meu papel seja como pessoa física como a
pessoa jurídica com uma pessoa
responsável e imaginar comportamentos
que tornem o mundo mais perigoso mais
respeitoso mais próximo mais humano mais
animal também produzam mais também fazem
parte desse mundo e mais comportamentos
e criar coisas que faz comportamentos
virarem realidade
então por exemplo imagine um mundo mais
colorido palavra que transforma em um
projeto que revitaliza lugares que estão
meio acabadinhas em escolas públicas
trazendo não só mais corpo a deixar que
um lugar muito mais colorido mas também
uma palavra que transforma
nesse caso uma escola pública escreveu
empatia e seu significado então os
alunos e alunas podem usar a quadra não
só um ficou um lugar muito mais
interessante que entra na quadra cinza
sem graça destruída uma transição também
ele compartilhando entendendo um
sentimento que é muito importante na
sociedade de hoje em dia
imagine um mundo onde as escolas não
servem apenas para ensinar aquilo que
cada vestibulando que ela seja um espaço
que nos ajudem a sermos melhores pessoas
é uma treta se adulto aí as escolas em
que nos preparam para isso
como não consigo sozinho mudar todas as
escolas a gente criou uma escola o
contrário
uma escola que só dá aulas sobre temas
que não cai no vestibular como propósito
como ansiedade como autoconhecimento
cidadania finanças
eu acredito mundo imagino um mundo onde
as empresas não são tão empresa assim
não são tão quadradas não são lugares
onde as pessoas são apenas um nome nunca
achar uma um número um no contra cheque
e sim um lugar onde elas possam elas
podem ser elas mesmas
henry podem fazer amizades podem chorar
podem contar suas dores no lugar de
jogar de apoio a essas pessoas
a gente faz isso traz dinâmica simples
mais profundas uma delas ao circo dos
sonhos onde toda uma empresa no final do
ano se reúne e sem divisão de cargos
cada pessoa faça o seu sonho da empresa
do ano seguinte a gente lista vários
sonhos
esses sonhos viram uma lista nominal e
eles passam a ser o nosso norte as
decisões da empresa não sei
em que se mantenham um sonho de todo
mundo imagina uma cidade mais viva mais
pulsante encadernação um evento que
convida pessoas a pegar uma cadeira
sentar na calçada por um dia e curtir um
espaço que geralmente elas não podiam
porque não têm bancos então espaço que
elas podem sentar tomar um chimarrão
conversar ouvir música de apartamento
que está ocupando a calçada a gente não
só deixa a cidade mais limpa mais
pulsante mas somente da cidade mais
segura
as pessoas na rua na cidade mais segura
imagina uma cidade que não só é mais
colorida mas viveu mais pulsante mais
uma cidade que também nos faça pensar
nos faz refletir nos provoque o time com
essa foi uma série de 50 anos que a
gente colocou o porto alegre 2015 2016
todos eles com uma frase inspiradora uma
pergunta provocativa para pegar as
pessoas de surpresa enquanto estivessem
caminhando o trabalho voltando à
academia
eu imagino o mundo onde os prédios e
condomínios são repletas de pessoas que
se conhecem são mais próximas
então eu virei o cara do grupo swatch
zap aonde eu vou morar eu criei um grupo
de outros afirma na mensagem do centro e
pasmem funciona não vi um grupo de
política de 61 pessoas estão falando
sobre a vida em condomínio podem parecer
exemplo simplórios um grupo de max ap um
lambe-lambe só mas eu gostaria que de
focar aqui não o que foi feito mas meu
pensamento por trás de cada ação e
gostaria que vocês pensassem no dia a
dia de vocês do que vocês imaginam antes
de fazer o que passa na cabeça de vocês
antes de fazer o que vocês fazem uma
pessoa imagina antes de você na outra no
final porque ela demorou 10 000 três
segundos para arrancar depois que não
abriu e que a gente imagina antes de
fechar o nosso vidro do carro morador de
rua que conversar com a gente e quem
imagina antes de trair um zoom parceiro
ou a parceira um sócio mas só se a gente
imagina de criar mais um prédio cinza
igual todos os outros créditos na cidade
esses são sem graça a gente imagina
pressa e imaginar
medo a gente imagina dos casos a gente
imagina praticidade imagina lucro e por
imaginar isso e fazer coisas com base
nesse pensamento
o mundo se torna assim esses dias eu fiz
uma pesquisa no instagram os meus
seguidores perguntando pra eles como
seria o mundo ideal pra vocês mas 40
pessoas responder a 45 50 50 pessoas
responderam fiz aqui um compilado e
todas as respostas
todo mundo todas as respostas falavam
algo que eu concordo
falavam do mundo que eu também quero
viver o mundo com mais respeito
o mundo sem poluição calmo e pacífico
sem diferença de classe sem violência
sem corrupção ea igualdade económica
social empático ea constante dos 23
graus na primavera o tempo inteiro
assim agora as florestas nesse mundo e
tenho a certeza que vai nessa pergunta e
jogar pra vocês
a maioria aqui o talvez todo mundo
responderei responderia algo dentro de
mim
nesse aspecto a gente sair para a rua e
perguntasse para 7 bilhões de pessoas
que estão lá fora essa mesma pergunta
tenho a certeza que a grande maioria
responderia o mundo meio que assim que a
gente válida a gente gosta e que a gente
gostaria de viver mas eu me pergunto por
que esse mundo não existe nem todo mundo
que é esse mundo todo mundo que quer se
mundo né
todo mundo lá fora também que também
quer o que não acontece não é o que tem
entre a barreira que existe entre o que
a gente quer que a gente tem
eu acho que essa reação porque o
comportamento a imaginação
aqui a gente sabe que a gente quer
começar a fazer coisas que talvez
coloquem isso em prática
estou falando que vai descer
megalomaníacos gigantesco criar um
megaprojeto a sobre a empresa e limpar o
oceano sozinhos
eu acho que ele pode fazer coisas muito
pequenas e que o mundo sem poluição
planta uma árvore entende que o mundo
com mais respeito
começa a praticar a comunicação não
violenta custa r$0 só precisa da nossa
voz
eu gostava tinha aqui ela mostra um uma
guimba floresta vai focando no peixinho
mega ingênua né tardin ele a chama de
onda não percebe o tamanho né daquilo
ali mas essa isso aqui eu é narrativa
padrão na ativa há a tinta renda da
entidade do peixe essa narrativa para a
sociedade de que para mudar o mundo a
gente tem que fazer algo grandioso
a gente tem que fazer uma super coisa
megalomania com muitas pessoas estavam
no mesmo tempo e acaba com a fome na
áfrica sozinho num dia
quanta gente já deixou de fazer algo
simplesmente achar que não ia adiantar
eu não vou juntar esse lixo está fazendo
isso não adianta nada só eu fazer então
seja pelo viaduto antológico design seja
pelo viés seja pela experiência de
várias pessoas que criam pequenas coisas
mudam realidades
eu tenho certeza que essa narrativa não
se sustenta
eu gosto muito da frase do economista
charles já está em que fala quando um
ponto de informação não se encaixa na
conversa ele faz com que esse universo
pode ser questionado e será ativa padrão
se o nosso universo que está ao nosso
redor e fala que a gente tem que fazer
algo melhor maneira de antecipar o mundo
eu prefiro seu ponto de informação que
faz o resto universo se questionar por
isso eu e luciano braga continua fazendo
projetos no plano pequenininhos não
importa onde eu estou com que eu tenho
as minhas ferramentas
vocês podem olhar isso de duas maneiras
1 e focando no tamanho do lago também da
floresta e no tamanho de vocês vou
pensar com o peixe questionar o universo
ao redor de vocês e criar um de volta
uma pequena ação de cada vez
obrigado pessoal
[Música]